hi there this is steve kaufman i'm uh
continuing in this series of of how i
use link for my check
hoping it might be helpful to some
people um
obviously for me uh in language learning
i want to
accumulate vocabulary and to me reading
and listening and linking
is the key to doing that now some people
like to read
content that has a very low percentage
of new words because it builds up
fluency and confidence and reading
it's a fine thing to do the only trouble
with it is that you you won't be adding
many new words on that basis
i tend to do the opposite i try to move
as quickly as possible into difficult
text
which i read on link originally and then
i'll eventually go and read books on the
same subject
so here i have from wikipedia a history
of czechoslovakia
uh which has a lot of new words in it
for me i mean it's a large large article
i think there's something like 30 new
words and and
which is a thousand new words but that
includes a lot of names so that's
not necessarily new words um and
and one of the things i like to do here
is um
obviously is is to save them but it's
difficult to remember i got all these
yellow words that i've saved i don't
necessarily remember them all
i want to slowly get a better sense of
these words
so one of the things i do is is i'll
notice in some of these words like
vivratil vrat you know and and
chileji tosti lege you know there are
these components you know zac
claudia claude uh vittorio twarge
rose rose claddal rose clada ladoz is
you know make a part like all these
rosacha
you know extended or whatever all these
components are key to learning
vocabulary so what i'll tend to do is
i'll take a word like this
pre-ledger trustee for example uh
and i'll open it up because i can't copy
in our
text as it is i can't copy and paste but
if i open up
the link then i can copy
the component that i'm interested in
copy
and then i'll go over to the vocabulary
section which i have open on another
page and here
i can um you know
look for here i was looking at p o z
but we're going to enter this l e delege
and we'll search for words that have
that component
in them and sure enough we come up with
there's
a number of words that mean important so
do
so i see this in a row and i can read
the
little captured phrases
very important to come to whatever so
okay that's the do legit
then pretty soon or most important nei
do legit
okay then we come to a different meaning
which is this
shilajitos that's the one i saw in that
article opportunity
priscilli tosti prisieritos nim in
different cases
and i look through these and i kind of
go over them a bit and then we get a
little further and we get to this matter
aspect zalezillo it depended on
zalejit depend on and then zalejitos
is a matter a concern and then in a
different
case setting so i review these and it
helps to it helps to
confirm what they mean now i could look
i could look i mentioned for example
that
rose which appears all the time and
which means separate
and so we can search for all words that
begin with rose
so you know those beat rose beta rose
bor
rosborough rose busca because very often
where you have uh words that seem to
have similar components it's confusing
to you you mix them up
and so it can either help you learn them
or it can confuse you so i find it very
useful to find these
lists of words that have components at
the beginning the middle or at the end
of a sentence and you use the asterisk
to uh either look at the
beginning of a word two asterisks with a
term in the middle
we'll give you that anywhere in the text
and then if you have the asterisk in
front then it'll look for endings
you can also choose only to look at your
category 1 like status 1 or 2 or
whatever
words you can look at your terms in the
vocab section by
creation date rather than alphabetically
but i like alphabetically because
it tends to line up these similar words
and the fact that i have saved
words that begin the same or are in fact
variations of the same word
really means that i didn't really
remember it from the first time i saved
it
and i save it in three four five six
different forms
then i review it and that all helps me
to remember it
uh the other thing i i mentioned by the
way any of these lists of course you can
display them 25 at a time
you can up to 100 at a time you can
select them all
you can flash card them close test print
import export and so forth
now the other thing here that i wanted
to mention was the
tags i tag my words i mentioned for
example that i tag words
that i call connector words because i
find them very
difficult to remember so afshak bhatt
beijing during which i now have learned
moved to four
so i could eliminate it from this list
and and not look at my known words
and so i look at all these but during
unfortunately thereby although on the
one hand but
more while if sometimes these are words
that i've called connector words
uh i could also look at for example the
accusative
you know i have saved words uh i have
saved words
uh in terms of their case again i don't
know how well you can
see this but i can then kind of review i
might even record these
record the actual term that i've saved
and the phrase that's been captured
record them so just in recording them
uh that's helping me because i'm saying
them and then i listen to them
so those are some of the things that you
can do in
your uh vocabulary page um
i think that's that's sort of enough on
the subject uh yeah you can as i say
you can uh sorry you can select all
and then you can delete you can that's
only for paying members by the way
or you can move all of them to known if
you want or you can change the status
up down up and down one you don't have
to
actually click on all you can click on
some and and and you can then perform
these
batch actions as well so that's it
now having looked up the pre-lege tosti
you know
i got a better feel now for that word so
i think the next time that i run across
pre-legit ostia or dulajiti or za
legitos
i'll have a better sense i'll get closer
maybe i can maybe i should even move
that up a status here maybe i'm at
status 2 on this now rather than status
one
okay thank you for listening